[Music]
welcome back to harbor on box today
we're embarking on part one of our
journey to look at almost every single
5,600 XD graphics card in fact there's
just one or two models from ASRock that
I wasn't able to get as they're not
selling in Australia but not to worry we
have a dozen models in house and they
cover all the popular versions so this
video will be covering the more
entry-level models and that means we
have the soos tough gaming x3 5600 XT
Evo you see a ridiculous name there but
also not that unusual as frustrating as
that might be we also have the power
color 5600 XT red dragon a much better
product name it has to be said there's
also the gigabyte 5600 XT win for cyrusi
MSI's 5600 xt mac OS e they skip the
evoke this time we also have the
sapphire 5600 xt pulse which was
featured in our day 1 review and then
the XFX 5600 xt thick 2 pro all of which
a price between 280 and $300 us since we
do have a lot of new data to go over and
this isn't an individual prior review
I'll be skipping over the usual teardown
stuff for each model as that would push
the videos runtime out to almost an hour
also while it is interesting to see how
each model is designed and put together
the proof as they say really is in the
pudding or in this instance the blue bar
graphs also many of these 5600 xt IRB
cards have borrowed their cooler from
the bigger 5700 series cards which we've
already looked at in quite a bit of
detail so no need to go over all that
again for testing i'm using our standard
GPU test rig which is built inside the
corsair crystal 570 x and of course
we're testing with all the glass panels
installed though please note the system
is fully populated with 120-millimeter
fans so airflow is still quite good
despite the all glass design also please
note each model has been flashed to the
latest v bios so that means those that
shipped early on with 12 gigabits per
second memory but were later updated to
support for 10 gigabits per second and
now running up to faster memory speed in
fact to make it a little easy to follow
because obviously it is very confusing
with how AMD botched this launch here is
a table comparing all six models using
the current spec finally any models with
dual biases they were tested in
maximum performance murder all right so
let's start by looking at a single frame
rate comparison graph using f1 2019 and
then we'll dive into the clock speeds
temps and operating volume the FPS
results are a good place to start as we
can clearly see which models are really
overclocked and which ones operate
closer to the AMD base spec as you can
see the gigabyte windforce OC and MSM
echo c really aren't that OC they both
only boost to an advertised clock speed
of sixteen hundred and 20 megahertz and
they use 12 gigabits per second memory
and they saw them averaged just shy of
100 FPS on f1 2019 test the models
supporting 14 gigabits per second memory
all operate their cores at over
seventeen hundred megahertz and this
resulted in about a ten percent
performance uplift interestingly power
color still to this day advertises the
red dragon as only having a sixteen
hundred and 20 megahertz boost clock but
with the newer 14 gigabits per second
bios it boosted up to seventeen hundred
and twenty five megahertz and it's the
same story with the XFX thick two pro
the official product page says it's up
to sixteen hundred and twenty megahertz
for the cause and twelve gigabits per
second for the memory but the latest
bars available from the XFX website
pushes the memory up to fourteen
gigabits per second and the cores reach
about seventeen hundred and thirty six
megahertz a seuss on the other hand they
advertise the tough with the crack clock
speeds but it still says it comes with
twelve gigabits per second memory when
in fact it has been upgraded to a four
ten gigabits per second memory so
sapphire is the only AIB partner to get
both the core and memory specs correct
anyway as we can see he in reality with
the latest B BIOS the sapphire pulse the
XFX thick two pro asustor fever and
power color a dragon all used the
maximum AIB OC spec from AMD and here's
a look at the peak operating clock
speeds when testing with f1 2019 again
those max OC models all operate between
seventeen hundred and twenty five and at
seventeen hundred and forty five
megahertz
while the base model from MSI an
gigabyte run at around 1600 megahertz
okay so here's a look at the GPU edge
temperature using the error box
configuration so no alterations made to
the fan speed there's really no duds
here the hottest model the power color
red dragon picked adjust 72 degrees
which is still very cool of
course the asou stuff Evo looks great
hitting just 58 degrees and we know that
cooler is quite good having recently
tested it on the revised 5700 xt model
the MSA MEC OC and gigabyte wind force
OC also looked quite good running at
under 70 degrees but remember these
models are operating the cause and
memory at much lower frequencies so
you're looking at quite a large
reduction in power usage and that makes
the thermal result less impressive then
we have the sapphire pulse which I have
to say does look rather subpar here but
that particular model does operate it's
fans and a very low rpm and we'll look
at that very soon
along with some normalized rpm testing
here's a look at the GPU hot spot
temperatures and we do see quite a large
difference in performance between the
best and worst models again the asou
stuff evo does well peaking at just 72
degrees while the lower clock MSI and
gigabyte models also look good though
they are almost cheating this test the
pulse and red dragon deliver acceptable
results but it's the XFX thick 2 pro
that is of concern here picking at 91
degrees which is still within spec but
much hotter than the competing models
here's a look at out of the box GDD are
6 memory temperatures and surprisingly
the thick 2 pro is able to match their
suits tough Evo at just 74 degrees the
sapphire pulse also performs well
hitting 76 degrees while the MSI Mac you
see also much that temperature but
remember that particular model is
operating its memory at just 12 gigabits
per second this also makes the gigabyte
windforce OC result quite disappointing
as it - runs the memory at just 12
cubits per second then we have the red
dragon it's the least impressive model
hitting 80 degrees there it's still well
within safe operating parameters the GPU
power consumption figures are
interesting via seuss XFX sapphire and
power color results are all within 7
watts of one another which is typically
what you'd expect to see and they all
ran at around 140 watts then we have the
wind force OC which operates it scores
around 6% low and the models just
mentioned and it sees a four to nine
percent reduction in power depending on
which four 10 gigabits per second car
you use for comparison the Mecca RC on
the other hand peaked at just 109 watts
making it considerably less power-hungry
than all other tested 5600 XT graphics
cards that's around a 16% reduction in
power usage when compared to the wind
force OSI model which up
right at the same clock speeds it
appears MSI has optimized the voltages
at which their mech OC operates at and
under full load in our stress test the
card peaked at 900 millivolts the
sapphire pulse for example runs up to
nine hundred and 70 millivolts and
that's an 8% increase in voltage so when
you combine the lower voltage with the
lower clock frequency you get quite a
substantial reduction in power usage and
given that advantage you would expect
the macro you see to perform well in the
thermal tests now here's a look at out
of the box fan speeds using the current
V bio speech model incredibly the
sapphire pulse spins it's two fans are
just 950 rpm which is the slowest fan
speed of any of these 5600 XT models by
quite some margin in fact next best was
the power color red dragon operating it
just 1200 rpm and the Mac OS e at 14
hundred and 50 rpm the XFX thick 2 pro
and a soo stuff Evo both operate at
eighteen hundred and fifty rpm so that
helps explain why the asou Scott runs so
cool it's forcing air over the heatsink
and a much more rapid rate when compared
to the power color and Sapphire models
for example then we have the gigabyte
win four so ec and well this one lives
up to its name with a fan speed of
nineteen hundred and fifty rpm
unsurprisingly the sapphire pulse is by
far the quietest generating just 35
decibels of noise followed by the red
dragon at 38 decibels near Messiah echo
C is also very quite at 41 decibels but
as we just saw it is quite a bit slower
than the sapphire and power color models
still it does run a few degrees cooler
the thick two pro and tough evil or less
impressive here especially when compared
to the sapphire pulse while the wind
force OC is once again very unimpressive
okay so I went back and tested all six
models with the fans locked at 1600 rpm
and here they generated between 42 and
44 decibels of noise doing this
highlights just how much better the
sapphire pulses when compared to the
rest of the pack whereas the pulse
picked at a GPU temperature of just 59
degrees the out of the box champ the
asustor fever hits 64 degrees certainly
not a bad result for a soos but as I
said it does highlight just how good the
pulse really is the Mercosur also peaked
at just 64 degrees which is again a
solid result though not amazing given
this particular model sips power rally
to the rest of the cards tested there a
dragon doesn't fare quite as well as I
had expected still 66° is quite
impressive but ultimately it is beaten
by the tough Eva and easily beaten by
the sapphire pulse the XFX thick - Pro
it has to be said was very disappointing
hitting 73 degrees and that means very
similar operating volume it runs 14
degrees hotter than the pulse but even
more disappointing was the wind force OC
which of course is much slower than
thick - Pro and yet it reached 73
degrees but here we see it is the hot
spot temperature that's the major issue
for XFX and this problem was also seen
with the other box fan profile but here
with a slightly lower fan speed the
issue becomes very evident peaking at 97
degrees isn't a good result period but
it's particularly bad when most of the
models ran below 80 degrees the sapphire
pulse is again class-leading here
peaking at just 69 degrees which is
incredible given the edge temperature
for the XFX and gigabyte cards were
actually higher than that again we set
the asou stuff Eva on power color red
dragon also performed quite well though
they're a far cry from being able to
match the pulse even when it comes to GD
our six memory temperatures the pulse is
in a class of its own peaking at just 64
degrees making it 8 degrees cooler than
the next best contender power colors red
dragon and just lastly for reference
here's the recorded operating volume
results for each model and locked at a
1600 rpm fan speed alright so we've seen
how these six 5600 XT graphics cards
compare now it's time to draw a few
conclusions from the data in terms of
performance the sapphire pulse is
clearly the best here beating its
nearest competitors the red dragon and
tough Evo by at least 5 degrees when
comparing the edge temperatures and then
9 degrees when comparing the hot spot
temperatures in our RPM normalized
testing and although it's not the
coolest running 5600 XT out of the box
it is the quietest and in terms of
actual gaming performance it doesn't
matter too much if the hot spot tempers
72 degrees which was the case for the
tough Evo or 83 degrees in the case of
the pulse despite running 11 degrees
hotter the pulse was actually the
fastest model in RF on 2019 test or be
it by a single frame which is within the
margin of error but the point is you're
looking at identical gaming performance
between these two models the Sapphire
card just happens
noticeably quieter and overall features
a higher quality cooler the sapphire
pulse also costs just $290 u.s. and that
is of course just ten dollars over the
MSRP which for such a high quality 5600
XT is excellent to see and availability
has been strong since release of course
the asou stuff gaming x3 5600 xt evo OC
has a really long name but it performed
very well out of the box and would be my
second choice out of this bunch
the only issue being it generally sells
for a little over $300 u.s. with $300
being about the lowest that's gone on
sale for so that price it is very much a
forced second choice for me that also
means the power color 5600 xt red dragon
came in third and again it generally
costs around $300 so I'd only recommend
this model if the pulse isn't available
the XFX 5600 xt thick 2 pro is a hard
pass those hotspot temps are troubling
and the thermals in general were subpar
the only thing going for the thick 2 pro
is the price it can quite easily be had
for $280 but really saving $10 over the
pulse simply isn't worth it the thing
would have to be at least 30 to 40
dollars cheaper for me to consider it
then we have the MSI Mac OS it's a
pretty weak offering really and without
v-bar support for higher core in memory
clock speeds it simply isn't worth a
$300 asking price the gigabyte win for
so ii see it is quite a bit cheaper at
$280 but the cooler on this thing is
pretty poor really basically i'd
recommend you avoid it so there's half a
dozen entry-level 5600 XTS and we've
managed to quite clearly narrow the
buying decision down to a single model
with a decent backup very soon I will
update this content with the XFX 5600 xt
thick 2 pro power color 5600 xt red
devil msi 5600 xt gaming z gigabyte 5600
xt gaming OC a seuss ROG Strix 5600 XT
and the asrock 5600 XT found him gaming
d3 so it'll be interesting to see how
the more expensive models compare in
part 2 of this series which will be
coming up on the channel very shortly so
make sure you keep an eye out for that
but that is going to do it for now so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this look at
half-a-dozen 5,600 X T's and yukine
see how the more expensive models will
stack up and again as I said we will be
doing that very shortly in the meantime
you can like subscribe to the channel
you can also consider joining us over on
patreon to get access to our exclusive
discord chat monthly live stream and Q&A
as well some behind the scenes videos
anyway thank you for watching I'm your
host Steve and I'll see you again next
time
[Music]